[Music]
in Chinese cheating news Paul from
Portland India poor Lambie can you say
hi I'm a UCLA grad was arrested for
running a cheating ring cheating
cheating ring oh you mean like test
cheating probably because when you think
Chinese and cheating you don't think
sexual you think grades sexual I [ __ ]
up on my stereotypical [ __ ] so this is a
another scandal coming out of UCLA
because you know how the whole college
is bribing College Admission oh yeah
damn what's that you see you like yeah
can I guess what the scammy watch oh
well they already said it they did they
said what exactly the stem was cheating
ring I mean yeah but can I tell you what
the scam is yes this is what I think it
is okay so let's say Bart is is it is a
Chinese immigrant student it's a hard
thing to it picture right Nihao Bartley
right right so it let's let's call him
Bart Quan
okay okay okay he's very rich is a
student at UCLA yeah but he don't want
to fund and go to school
no way man [ __ ] that you know he's gonna
get Joe Chau over here to be bar Quan
take the [ __ ] tests ace all of them
and be the student yeah tell me I'm
right I mean yeah we'll see you guys the
next video Thanks I heard of this racket
because there's people out there that's
making hundreds of thousands of [ __ ]
dollars pertaining to be somebody else
that's like what the Lori Loughlin [ __ ]
was the college admissions got a thing
our users
where they had a guy taking tests for
the kids yeah doesn't you seem like is
that right to do that just a fake be
somebody else in college like these
teachers don't know you yeah there's
like a hundred students in a class
sometimes you've been that students
since day one no no no teachers don't
care yeah we just go pressure and I
don't know about this news or here I was
hearing rumors of that happening and
people making loads of money yeah so FBI
have arrested six people involving
involved in this scheme and that's
pretty much what they were doing is that
they would this one guy that was the
head of everything he would hire people
to pose as the students so then they
could take their English proficiency
test that which is required to obtain a
u.s. student visa and so he would also
have people just take different exams so
he paid to register fourteen people for
this one exam and then paid three other
test takers four hundred dollars per per
exam in 2015 and 2016 and this ring
wieder he's 23 years old
wait you don't four hundred bucks per
exam for the test takers yeah so he
would yeah so it was so funny because
this guy kind of could have gotten away
with it it seems but the reason why he
got caught is because he charged all
these things on one credit card so
that's why he got cut so wait why is
this bad says he he's cheating himself
so I see that but what why does the FBI
have to get involved because these are
is it consist because it's racketeering
because of the u.s. student visas oh the
visas involve got it okay illegal got it
yeah yeah cuz the other one that the
rumor that I heard was not for visas it
was more for like a student's whole
career yeah that's that too there's this
one so they do multiple things well
there was this one story of this article
that they use at this one guy he was a
Chinese student and he spent nearly 1.2
million dollars just to not go to school
because initially
[ __ ] that's crazy there was a student
who faked his score to get into Purdue
University and once he got there he paid
someone to attend classes for him and
then his employees grades were good
enough that he got into Columbia
University for grad school but then he
was struggling so he hired someone to
take his classes there too and so he was
hoping the landed job at Goldman Sachs
and so that's when he saw this one
particular person's help and then he was
just saying that like his English was at
a high school level because we just kept
paying other people to do his work so
that's why it ended up being nearly 1.2
million dollars just to not go to school
do you even need to go to school if you
just pay one point to milk I know right
aren't you tired that's I mean isn't it
like the Chinese parents really like you
need to have a degree kind of thing yeah
but if you have that's cuz they don't
have one point to laying around like
that so you need to have a degree to get
a job no even rich she's talking about
even yeah yeah like like prestige wise
you know it's not really about the money
but the the Honor legacy yeah he's
trying to get a job he's trying to go to
Goldman Sachs and get a job that's funny
now this is thing that it's like Oh a
lot of people didn't really hear about
this because of the admissions scam or
scandal but it all happened in the same
actually exact same date [ __ ] I mean
it's like it's still happening right now
with different teams too that's like
imagine your kid went missing the same
day that Natalie Holloway went missing
like damn dude you will nobodies cares
about your story yeah like remember that
blonde chick like years ago on like a
ruber some [ __ ] well she was a pretty
white girl and so when she went missing
was a crazy huge thing and then people
who had missing kids in the same time
zone nobody before it's called Test of
English as a foreign language or the
TOEFL hopeful so they're calling this a
TOEFL exam
I mean scam damn is wild there's guys
out there that like roll around and I'm
like Ferraris and Lamborghinis and stuff
and all they do is pretend to be
students and in and I I think uh
you're a high commodity like if like
let's say you have like an engineering
degree or you're like these guys let's
say they're full-on engineers so though
ace all the tests and all that stuff so
for them they're making more money being
students I mean they're rolling around
and Ferraris and Lamborghinis students
that's the stupidest thing I ever heard
you wanna pretend be a student be broke
ass buggy top ramens yeah they're in
debt as [ __ ] yeah that's how you get
caught you drive a Toyota Corolla that
you can barely pay for and look saddled
without the bicycle and we're cat you're
polish yeah Jesus and smell like weed
dude my sister is in student loan debt
where the government is profiting off of
her [ __ ] student loan debt the
governing off of this [ __ ] it's crazy
you know how I'm a student loan system
used to be like when when we were going
to school it was like they don't
actually charge you until you graduate
yes right but that's it's different no
no no no I mean now you have to pay your
why the the month that you sign up and
you get that money it's like it's like a
regular personal loan you can get in
legal trouble if you don't pay it's
crazy
no no no they they can just just start
taking from your paycheck IRS you're the
gummies will ya it's crippling because
that's why there's some people that it's
like how did you end up in $80,000 debt
and you've only been to school for like
two semesters what the [ __ ] happened and
it's because they start charging you
from the muff that you're already a
student which is stupid and there's no
one to regulate the prices cuz they just
keep going up but it's like wait why I
look silly because the loans are secured
by the government so so the universities
are in cahoots with the government so
they can raise prices and the
government's will match those with loans
they'll subsidize e that's what the
whole system set up for everyone to
[ __ ] win except for the students
that's where the next recession is
coming I agree there's a problem ideally
any student Bob will happen again and
it's gonna burst because what's
happening is like so let's say you have
a lot of debt right and then you're
gonna be [ __ ] either way you graduate
or if you don't because let's say
you something happened you have to take
a break from school if you didn't get
your degree you still don't get that
higher paid job or whatever it is right
so you're gonna kind of default on your
loans you can't pay for it let's say you
do get your degree but you're just
starting off so you have four hundred
three hundred thousand dollars in debt
but then you're just starting off as a
pharmacist or whatever right that's a
[ __ ] huge load to pay you're paying to
rent bills every morning so in it and by
that time it already compounded so like
your your debt could have been two
hundred thousand so butBut they already
slapped on a hundred thousand extra
right and then all these people are just
gonna go broke they're gonna have broke
pharmacists that are like I can't pay
this [ __ ] [ __ ] it I'm not gonna it
should be illegal for the government to
profit off of the [ __ ] citizens who
are getting loans because that's the
whole idea behind the program right
that's what that was the idea behind it
we're it incentivizes Americans to go to
college to get better education so they
write better lives because the long-term
health of this country yes when you have
smarter people and all that stuff it's
gonna be more doctors more lawyers all
that stuff's good for all of us right
right so that so that's why they did
they set up the program that way but
then they're like wait a minute we can
all [ __ ] profit off of those and the
colleges can keep raising rates so we
all just keep winning and professors can
make like outlandish salaries like and
they only have to worry about anything
because once they get tenure they're sad
so they just all kind of coast and then
it's all all the pressure goes on the
students heads were ultimately royally
for toilet the house of cards is gonna
fall because if a lot of people owe all
this money right and they can't pay it
and it's gonna start like crumbling
housing crisis 2.0 that's exactly what
happened so like people couldn't pay
their house loans and they were giving
them out like candy and then it started
crumbling right so same [ __ ]
so nobody breathe let's hope the economy
works because if it doesn't that's the
first thing that'll pop that's only cuz
it I mean my cousin my nephew was 19 my
mom's I mean his mom is constantly
pressuring me to be like come on change
his mind like I can't get to him I want
my voters school gate degree but then
I'm like well wait doesn't even know
what he wants to do and then you're
setting them up to be in debt so I'm
like just have him chill
no their generation they're even way
further back they don't even know
because we had good financial aid still
when we were going to school
we pretty much went for free I got a car
with that money like I still left with
Deb but nothing nothing like what these
guys are going I had like maybe 2,000
bucks and people are choosing degrees
now that's like [ __ ] like dance
theory or whatever and you're [ __ ]
you'll never make money off oh yeah
going to debt and they don't have
anything that generates income anything
in the humanities your [ __ ] mad start a
YouTube channel but then your parents
[ __ ] you over because they got too
into College Admission scandal Jade Jade
chick Olivia Jade chick man more chick
feel so bad for her yeah she could have
got you in C
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]